but right now uh back from the tampa bay
times fresh off of this monday night
loss for the bucks that he covers
uh rick stroud rick i feel like every
single time i have you on you i i hold
you responsible with what's going on in
tampa
[Laughter]
it's all my fault actually maybe bruce
aryan should read talking to goats
because there seems to be a lack of
communication there
well let's get into that let's get into
that i i give you the floor on what you
think happened last night
what happened what i'm with you i mean i
was stunned
i think the conversation today should be
about sean mcvay turtling
uh in a situation where you give the
ball back to tom brady
uh you know with with two minutes and a
timeout meaning only a field goal to tie
and a touchdown to win i mean
this guy has 39 fourth quarter comebacks
or something like that
i mean it's unreal what his record is
and it should have been the story
but we have seen you know tom brady
struggle now
uh against good defenses not against
everybody and he tore carolina up
obviously
but against good defenses and really
struggled
throwing the ball down the field and in
that situation
i'm not even sure you need to take a
shot right there i mean you just
you know completed a ball to mike evans
you're close to midfield
just run your two-minute offense or
whatever it is you you typically do but
this is the problem is that there is
some sort of disconnect with tom brady
byron left which bruce arians whoever
you want to say
but if you talk to bruce he's like look
the guys are there you know when they're
open we got to hit him
one went off antonio brown's fingers
that was a misread on the final play he
put that on brady
you know bruce is calling him out for
and holding him accountable for every
mistake he's made
and against the good teams he's made a
ton of them i mean he's got
you know seven of his nine interceptions
have come against i think the saints and
and in the rams the two you know better
teams in the nfc
so for whatever reason and we we can we
drill this down every week
it's not happening and it's not
happening particularly throwing the ball
down the field so i know it's a team
game but you know
that's that's the problem when you bring
in a guy that for 20 years has done
nothing but take you to super bowls the
expectation is
he's you do the super bowl and he and he
hasn't been able to do that and now
you know they got the world champions
coming in here on sunday
uh and they could be you know by the end
of the day next sunday they could be
looking at
seven and five and hoping to uh to to
win out or
do really well in the final four games
just to make the playoffs well before we
get to turn the page let's just linger a
little bit on what we've just seen and
and and and what we have seen
um you know i mentioned at the top of
the show that nobody really in the nfl
wants to start with 12 straight weeks i
mean a bye week and week 13 is not what
you would normally circle and go okay
but you know if you haven't had uh
otas you haven't had anything but public
practices in the park to get on the same
page prior to a season
starting you want as many reps as you
possibly can get
and here we are in week 11 saying the
same things as we did in week one coming
off a loss is what was brady thinking or
is aryans you know calling him out in a
manner to with which brady is
uncomfortable
um and and brady's comfort level i had
aryans on it
last week and i asked him you know hey
kurt warner is telling me he doesn't
think that brady's comfortable in this
offense yet what do you think
and he agreed with that assessment i
asked him when he thought brady would be
comfortable in it then
he's laughed he said next spring and
you know i i don't think he was joking
rick
you know i don't know no rich i think
that's yeah i think that's possible
and you know i mean you could only get
so much done
you came in here the pandemic all of
those are really good excuses here's
another one
they kept adding to this football team
after they
started playing you know or were
beginning to play
i mean and jason wright has pretty much
you know
whether it was gronkowski in the
off-season or hey here's leonard
fournette let's bring him in oh
hey here's antonio brown let's bring him
in well when you do that
can you have too much talent in football
no um
but you know you were starting to hit
some strides a little bit
against the raiders which is a good
football team you're hitting some deep
balls to scottie miller and now scotty
miller is on the field
12-15 plays and i'm not saying that he's
a better player than antonio brown
but that just adds to the lack of
continuity that you're trying to build
you know there were guys that were
at least throwing with them back in
february or march at the high school at
berkeley prep
and you know they've continued you know
here's what they don't have
they don't have a running back who can
catch the ball beat man coverage and
make plays after the catch
you can say leonard burnett's caught
70-something balls in a season but you
know what he's not a route runner and he
dropped
three and they said you know brucerien
said just a few minutes ago that
two of those were on tom brady i mean
everything seems to come back to the
quarterback
and i had somebody tell me which is
unbelievable if you think about it
that brady might have a confidence
problem right now and
it's not that he's not a confident guy
my goodness he's played in the biggest
games
in the history of the of football and
won most of them
but as far as when he goes out there you
know you can see
that they're just you know they're
grasping at straws at times and
you know even though he's involved you
know what's the game planning what do
they do on the sidelines i mean bruce
said today he's over there on the
sideline between series picking the
plays that he wants to run and
sort of calling his own play so i don't
know it's uh
it's an issue and i don't think it's
going to change they still got you know
several weeks to to try to fix it but um
you know this this season's getting late
rick stroud the tampa eight times here
uh on the rich eisen show and what is
your assessment of of brady and aryans
i mean again uh we know that that you
know the narrative that brady after 20
years of belichick was looking for
a new situation and he found it in
aryans um
who is a lot more sharing publicly
with his thoughts uh certainly if they
are casting the the quarterback as a
mistake per uh mistake prone
um is there an issue at all
they say there isn't but what do you
think i mean i i'm not in that circle
but the people that are around tom every
day
right um you know in meetings and
whatnot
they say it never comes up you know
we've asked him about it and he seems a
little sullen he'll just go
to the default well you know he's a
coach i'm a player but i can't believe
rich that
you know for all the research that we
know tom brady did before he made this
decision to come to tampa and he had
many
places that he could have gone that he
didn't talk to peyton manning
or he didn't talk to ben roethlisberger
and that he didn't know
everything that he thought he was
getting with bruce aryans good
and bad you know it's that we lose we
booze baby but it's also
i'm going to call you out and i'm going
to call you out in public
and i'm going to tell you that i'm going
to do it don't take it personal it's
just because your football sucks
that's what he tells every player the
first meeting that he has every year
so if tom you know is hurt by this
yeah you know maybe you should you can't
ask the goat to have a thicker skin but
i mean
you know i think he wants to be
accountable i think he wants to see
the other players see him be held
accountable by bruce aaron's because
god knows you know brady's holding
everybody accountable
uh on the sidelines and in practice and
everywhere else so
that part might be a little overstated
it is shocking because we're used to
belichick
not saying anything but then what did he
say in private
um so yeah i i think some too much you
made
is made of that but if it all falls on
on tom's shoulders then
you know that that's where it was going
to go anyway rick stroud tampa bay times
couple more minutes left with him right
here on the rich eisen show okay so
let's let's
turn the page and let's go let's go
glass half full a little bit here
because it's not as if this is a four
and 17. there's seven and four
um there is a seven seed out there
uh as well um the only teams that could
maybe displace them in this game of
musical chairs are the five and five
bears or a trio of four and six teams
um so it's not like they're in danger of
missing the playoffs even if they do
lose
this coming week against kansas city um
you have the goat
again brady i i think those those throws
that that aries was pointing out that
didn't
connect with fournette came from
just quickly getting it out because the
offensive line is is banged up and
and potentially he's a little concerned
about his protection
but he's still he's still making some
great throws i mean he found
he found evans uh on this you know from
the opposite hash last night to a
sideline he's making the throws
i don't think it's his arm and then they
you do have an incredible
you know buck still do have an
incredible amount of talent question is
what is the fix like what do you think
these smart guys like aryans are going
to get together and
the fix is going to be what is it rick
what do you got for me
well it's a great it's a great question
i mean i think you know
it's week to week rich and that's the
league we live in right i mean you've
got a whole nother problem coming to you
you can't worry about what just happened
um these guys got the kansas city chiefs
who are extremely explosive
the bucks had trouble you know with some
of the quick throws and
and tackling um the rams receivers just
wait till they see kansas city
right um so you probably want to do
something a little different
and try to minimize the number of
possessions that you give
patrick mahomes i don't think you want
to get in the shootout
much like they really didn't want to get
in a shootout with the rams and they
kept the score
reasonable um so it's hard to know i
mean there's so little time you can't
fix everything right
you've got to hope you get ali marpet
back um you got to hope that
you know aq shipley who had a stinger
can play i mean they got issues
of just trying to figure out who's going
to go and then
it's a matter of you know executing and
and
one thing i know about tom brady in the
short time i've been around him
he's not very uh pleasant to be around
generally he's pretty focused but when
he loses
it's to be a rough week of practice for
everybody over there and he's going to
be hard on himself
so you know i think kansas city's got a
big edge here
don't be surprised if you don't see the
best game from tom brady
on sunday we haven't seen it week to
week and it's a great football
team but i do believe you're right that
they they play the falcons twice
they play minnesota and they finish i
think with detroit
or something like that that combination
so they still have a good chance of
making the postseason it'd be a lot
better to be a higher seed there's no
doubt about that you could find yourself
in green bay or something
but uh they're not giving up and and we
know this about brady i mean how many
times have people written the guy off
right of course
right and although he's never won a
championship playing
uh on wild card weekend which it sure
looks like they're that's true they're
going to do because they don't have the
tie break
against the saints and that's my last
question for you i'd be remiss if i
didn't ask you your two cents on
jameis still not getting the start with
brees out for three straight weeks and
the kid that you've been covering for so
many years now winding up in new orleans
um i don't know if there's any i know
you've got obviously the bucks in front
of you and
the saints are another team but uh i'm
wondering what your two cents are or
anything you've gleaned from
all of this well i was surprised
i really thought that this was going to
be the best shot that jameis would ever
have
uh in his career would be to you know
watching him come in and hold the fort
when
when drew got hurt um when you listen to
sean payton if you know a little bit
about
sean um you know i think he was excited
to have a chance to continue to evolve
his offense and see what taysom hill
could do
he drafted him as a quarterback they
paid him a lot of money
james is there for for one year one
million dollars you know
and and also you know sean payton has
seen james winston now
he knows what the good and the bad is uh
and he's looking to win football games
they don't want to drop off
and i just think he had a lot more
confidence in what he could do with
tyson hill and what hill would
would do in that system because he knows
it um whether he's thrown many passes or
not but yeah it's it's not a good thing
for jameis
um that they chose to go that way uh but
then again
you know he's on a winning football team
and and uh he's got to continue to do
the best he can if they need him
rick appreciate the time uh don't i
don't
you know don't uh i lose our number
cause we're gonna be calling you very
soon
again i have a feeling this is just a
fascinating i mean maybe maybe rich if
they win
if they win a game or two you can call
it well no i hey look i called you off
the win
uh against the giants you know what i
mean no but
it but it's just a it is amazing how
here we are it's thanksgiving week
we're still having the same questions in
week 11 that we had in week one despite
them winning seven
out of 11 right and and and
and it does appear that for brady to get
back to the super bowl
in his first season outside of new
england he's going to have to do
something he never did in new england
which he's already done in losing to a
division opponent twice
but it's it's make the super bowl from
wild card weekend which he never did it
sure looks like that's the way it's
going to be
but he does still have the most talented
uh cast around him it it's just
fascinating what a story
rick what a story it is a story and and
we know
he's up for the challenge no doubt uh
thanks for the call rick we'll chat soon
have a good thanksgiving with your
family that's rick stroud here in tampa
bay times
and i would be remiss if i did not
mention sean payton is our first guest
tomorrow
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here